Okay, ready?
Hello everyone.
For years,
for months,
you write to me to tell me your support.
To keep up with the work we do
in the European Parliament.
I hope I could,
with all the elected officials of our delegation,
be your spokesperson during this term.
Now I need your voice.
Our political family,
through the decision of Eric Suti,
trusted me to wear our colors in this
next European election.
We have 4 and a half months,
4 and a half months.
It will be very short to succeed in convincing
around you
all those who no longer believe in politics,
all those who, perhaps,
no longer believe in the right.
We have a duty to give them hope.
This election will be
decisive for the future of our continent
which is at a crossroads,
but also decisive,
obviously,
for the future of our democratic life.
In France,
it's time or never.
You can make a difference now.
Can you get closer
of your Republican federation
to know how
find your place.
I count on you,
see you soon